saggas suite obtuvo una multa por exceso
de la velocidad en su camino a casa de
su trabajo ok si paga su multa ahora no
habrá penalizaciones en el pago si
retrasa su pago entonces se evaluará una
penalización por el número de meses ten
ok que retrase el pago de su multa su
multa total
efe ok en euros está indicada atar la
siguiente estos números representan una
función exponencial eso es muy
importante y como estamos hablando de
una función exponencial vamos a recordar
a qué me refiero cuando digo una función
exponencial y bueno es que todas las
funciones exponenciales se ven de la
siguiente manera
efe dt ft es igual
a una constante a que multiplica a una
base oa una razón elevado a la t del
lujo a un radio o una razón elevado la
tela y bueno pues aquí tenemos la tabla
y dice el número de meses que se
retrasen
1 2 3 4 y bueno la cantidad que va a
pagar después de que pase cada uno de
estos meses en donde no pague su multa y
bueno pues la razón común entre los
valores consecutivos debe ser esa es mi
primera pregunta y para eso lo que hay
que recordar es algo muy importante
cuando el propio saber la razón es decir
esta ere la razón nos dice por cuánto
tenemos que multiplicar al mes anterior
para obtener en el siguiente y bueno lo
podemos ver con algún ejemplo la razón
la razón la podemos obtener como pues
supongamos efe 2
efe 2 / efe 1 ok o en su dado caso la
podemos obtener como no sé
efe 3 ok un mes siguiente entre el mes
anterior
efe 21 se tales lo podemos obtener como
efe 4 / efe 3 cuanto sirves lo podemos
ver una manera general la razón la
podemos ver como efe de temas uno de
temas uno
/ efe
/ efe ok esto es una manera general y
bueno si nosotros queremos calcular la
razón de esta función entonces lo que
tenemos que hacer es dividir
consecutivas
tengo que dividir esta entre esta para
obtener la razón o dicho otra manera
la razón es 450 entre 300 y 450 entre
300 y bueno esto es lo mismo que 1.5
esto es lo mismo que 1.5 y bueno si tú
quisieras saber de una manera general
porque me da esto la razón
utilizando esta fórmula keynes efe dt
más uno bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
a que a por r alarte más uno ok ya esto
lo voy a dividir entre este tema pero
este es a por ere a la t ok y si de
picante lo está y está me quedaría que
esto es exactamente lo mismo que ere de
temas uno de temas uno que es esta parte
de aquí y ésta está dividiendo por lo
tanto menos
y ahora te das cuenta que este y este se
van y solamente me queda el a uno lo
cual es precisamente r por lo tanto la
razón la podemos obtener justo con esta
fórmula de aquí y ya podemos escribir
aquí 450 entre 300 es lo mismo que 1.5
1.5 así que ya sabemos algo de esta
función exponencial lo que sabemos es
que esta función exponencial
efe dt ft se ve de la siguiente manera
como am que multiplica a una razón pero
la razón ya la sabemos que es 1.5 esto
que multiplica a 1.5 elevado a la t
elevado a la t de lujo ahora lo que nos
preguntan es escribir una fórmula para
esta función y bueno aquí tengo ya la
fórmula de esta función pero me hace
falta encontrar el valor de amd y para
encontrar el valor de amd podemos
sustituir cualquiera de estos meses
porque ya tenemos cuánto vale cada uno
de ellos es decir para hacerlo en el
caso más fácil vamos a ver quiénes f1 a
f1 ok es lo mismo que a
r pero el 1.5 a que multiplica a 1.5 ok
esto elevado a la primera potencia ok y
esto es lo mismo según lo que me dice la
tabla a 300 esto es lo mismo que 300 ok
o dicho de otra manera va a ser igual a
300 a 300 entre 1.5 elevado a la 1 lo
cual es 1.5 1.5 y bueno 300 entre 1.5
esto está muy fácil esto es lo mismo que
200 200 de lujo y entonces ya sé cuánto
vale o dicho de otra manera ya podemos
encontrar la fórmula completa con el
valor de aquí con el valor de la razón
ok de esta base de ft efe es lo mismo
que es más déjeme escribirlo así ft ft
es lo mismo que a pero ah vale 200 es
decir 200 que multiplica a 1.5 que es la
razón a 1.5 él
alarte está elevado a su vez al tema de
lujo y ya tenemos la segunda respuesta
ahora lo que nos dice la tercera
pregunta es cuál es la multa en euros
que esa la tienen que pagar sí porque me
falta una y si lo hace a tiempo y bueno
esencialmente lo que me están
preguntando aquí es si no se retrasen
ningún mes dicho de otra manera estoy
buscando
efe de cero efe de cero y justo es lo
que tengo que poner aquí
efe de cero o dejarlo aquí mejor antes y
militar esto aquí lo que voy a poner es
efe de cero
pero si no nos retrasamos ningún mes en
pagar esta multa y bueno si te das
cuenta la razón es una cosa muy
importante porque si yo multiplico a 300
por la razón obtengo 450 vamos a verlo
así si yo multiplico a 300 x por 1.5
obtengo 3 455 450 lo multiplicó otra vez
por la razón entonces voy a obtener a
675 esto por 1.5 me da 675 y si a esto
lo multiplicó de nuevo por 1.5 lo
multiplicó por 1.5 obtengo esta cantidad
de aquí o dicho de otra manera lo que me
estoy refiriendo es que si a este número
lo divido entre la razón ok
obtengo este número de aquí si este
número lo divido entre la razón entre la
razón obtengo este número de aquí y sea
esto lo divido entre la razón obtengo
este número de aquí y por qué te digo
todo esto bueno porque si nosotros
queremos encontrar
efe de cero hay dos formas de hacerlo la
primera es a esta cantidad de aquí
dividir la otra
/ la razón es decir ir un paso antes o
calcular efe 0 con la fórmula que
tenemos aquí vamos a hacerlo de las dos
maneras si yo divido 300 300 entre 1.5
que es la razón esto me va a dar a es lo
mismo que tenemos aquí esto es lo mismo
que 200 ok esto por una parte y bueno ya
lo podría concluir aquí doscientos euros
ahora también lo podemos hacer
utilizando la fórmula que acabamos de
encontrar
efe de cero efe de cero es igual a 200
por 1.5 1.5 elevado a la potencia 0
ahora lo padre es que 1.5 elevado a la
potencia cero esto es 1 pero tanto me
queda 200 por 1 que es otra vez estos
200 de aquí y esta es la solución de la
tercera pregunta por lo tanto ya tenemos
todo en este problema
sara swift si paga tiempo entonces va a
pagar 200 euros